a lot of late night hosts out there they
do it the same way they come out and
they tell
some monologue jokes okay and they all
do it
just like everybody not this guy
i like to innovate sorry other hosts
but that's the way i roll i'm conan the
innovator
a name that never caught on anyway i've
found a great
way to tell topical jokes that also adds
excitement
and sex appeal check this out
in north carolina president trump told
supporters to vote twice
once by mail once in person trump said
it's crucial
that i win both elections
conan's lighting up the darkness
fighting fascists and their lies
all the people will rejoice when donald
trump cries
um what was that what are you talking
about i'm fighting fascism with my jokes
andy
hey it's come out that melania trump
used her own private email to conduct
official business isn't that shocking
melania trump has official business
set up punch means devastation conan set
the world on fire
human pathos and insight there's no art
form
here i i'm sorry but i don't think these
jokes deserve this much
fanfare well you're wrong
this week grey's anatomy will begin
filming its 17th season
yeah the big changes that now grey's
anatomy is named after the cast
hair really on color roll now
singing targets left and right going
after hollywood he's fighting
the good fight
i hope you don't get canceled for that
one in a recent speech
the pope urged people to live a simpler
more austere life
yeah then he took off his
diamond-studded hat went back into his
palace
conan joked about the pope i don't know
if that's okay
but i'll sing most anything as long as
they pay yeah
okay your uh 80s singer is getting kind
of lazy now
well forget that
he's going to be great he's gonna really
get it with this one
one more at a zoo in thailand a visitor
was caught
fondling a tiger's testicles yeah after
hearing about it
tigers in the wild began turning
themselves in
[Music]
how was that andy oh i'm sorry
i was i was checking my email oh okay
anyway we got a terrific show tonight
beth stelling's gonna be joining us
we'll take a break we'll be right back
[Music]
you